From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. And I could say a lot of things right now to explain what we're doing on the program today. But honestly, I think everything you need to know can be explained with this phone call.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。此时此刻，我可以用很多话来解释我们今天节目要做什么。但说实话，我觉得你们需要知道的一切，通过这通电话就能解释清楚。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hey, Bill here.
嘿，我是比尔。
Hey, Bill.
嘿，比尔。
Hey. I had a fellow-- he was walking across the country like a dummy. And it's cold weather. And I was going to put him up at the barbecue shed. But I got to thinking about it. And it was warm out here in my shop. So I just brought him on down to my shop.
嘿。我这有个小伙子——他像个傻瓜一样徒步横穿全国。而且天气很冷。我本来打算让他住在烧烤棚里。但我转念一想，我的店里很暖和。所以我干脆把他带到我的店里来了。
He looked like a clean cut guy. And I didn't want no bum staying here. But I believe he'll be all right. Huh?
他看起来是个正派的孩子。我不想让流浪汉住在这儿。但我相信他没问题。啊？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
He just walking across the country. He said he's going to-- where you going to wind up at?
他正徒步横穿全国。他说他要——你打算去哪儿？
New Orleans and then California.
新奥尔良，然后去加州。
He's going to walk from New Orleans. And then he's going on to California. And he just bumming around. Look like his pants are pretty clean. Now, where'd you come from?
他要从新奥尔良走。然后去加州。他就在那到处流浪。你看他的裤子挺干净的。对了，你从哪儿来？
Philadelphia.
费城。
He come from Philadelphia. Got to [INAUDIBLE] this morning and walked to right here.
他从费城来。今天早上到了这儿，然后一直走到这儿。
You don't know his name?
你不知道他的名字？
Yeah. What's your name?
知道啊。你叫什么名字？
Andrew Forsthoefel.
安德鲁·福斯特霍费尔。
Andrew Forsthoefel. Now ain't that a name? Andrew Forsthoefel. Yeah, you ever heard of that? Forsthoefel? Now that's a crazy name, ain't it?
安德鲁·福斯特霍费尔。这名字不错吧？安德鲁·福斯特霍费尔。你听过这个名字吗？福斯特霍费尔？这名字挺疯狂的，对吧？
That's different. We ain't got nobody around here that name, have we? I frisked him down. He ain't got no gun on him or no pistol. Huh?
那可真独特。我们这儿可没叫这名的人，是吧？我搜过他的身了。他身上没带枪也没带手枪。啊？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
I don't know why he's doing it. He's just crazy, I think.
我不知道他为什么要这么做。我觉得他就是疯了。
So to hear Andrew Forsthoefel tell it, last year he found himself walking across America by accident. He took a job when he got out of college. Three months in, he got fired. Wasn't sure what to do next.
据安德鲁·福斯特霍费尔自己说，去年他意外地开始徒步横穿美国。大学毕业后他找了份工作。干了三个月，被解雇了。不知道接下来该做什么。
And he just figured he'd start walking. He didn't have much money, didn't have a plan. He walked out of his back door near Philadelphia down to New Orleans. And then he figured he would just see if he felt like going further. And he did, all the way to the Pacific. He walked 4,000 miles.
于是他想，干脆开始走路吧。他没什么钱，也没有计划。他从费城附近的后门走出来，一路走到新奥尔良。然后他想看看自己还有没有力气继续走下去。他确实走下去了，一直走到太平洋海岸。他走了4000英里。
Today on our program, we have three stories of people hitting the road. And they're full of hope. And they're not sure what to expect. And they're launching themselves into the future.
今天在我们的节目中，有三个关于人们踏上旅程的故事。他们充满了希望。他们不确定会遇到什么。他们正将自己投向未来。
And I will tell you truthfully, I am not so keen on this kind of story. On the radio, I think, this kind of story usually sucks, because where is the surprise?
我老实告诉你们，我对这类故事并不怎么感冒。我觉得在广播里，这类故事通常很烂，因为惊喜在哪儿呢？
What is there to say about the thrill of the open highway that isn't already in the lyrics to "Thunder Road," or in Jack Kerouac, or in every road trip movie ever made from Easy Rider to National Lampoon's Vacation.
关于公路旅行的刺激，除了《Thunder Road》的歌词，或者杰克·凯鲁亚克，或者从《逍遥骑士》到《疯狂假期》等每一部公路电影里提到的东西，还有什么可说的呢？
Andrew did the thing that shouldn't work at all as a radio story. He started walking across America, didn't know exactly why he wanted to do it. But he did have a mission, sort of. He was 23. And he had a vague kind of sense that he was going to ask people what advice they would give their 23-year-old selves? And that's pretty good, actually.
安德鲁做了一件在广播故事里根本不该成功的事。他开始徒步横穿美国，也不清楚自己为什么要这么做。但他确实有一个任务，某种程度上算有吧。他23岁。他有一个模糊的念头，想要问问人们会给23岁的自己什么建议？说实话，这还挺不错的。
He took a recorder with him just in case, and ended up recording 85 hours of stuff. When he got done, he got help from this website that exists to encourage people to make their own audio stories. It's called transom.org.
他随身带了一个录音机以防万一，最终录下了85个小时的素材。做完之后，他在一个鼓励人们制作个人音频故事的网站（transom.org）上获得了帮助。
That's where to go, by the way, if you're ever thinking of making a radio story yourself. The guy who runs the site, Jay Allison, helped Andrew shape his 85 hours of audio into a story.
顺便说一下，如果你也考虑自己制作广播故事，就去那个网站。经营该网站的杰·艾利森帮助安德鲁将他那85小时的音频整理成了一个故事。
Some friends wrote and played original music. That's the music you're going to hear throughout. And what I like about it is you actually get a sense of what it would be like to walk across America. We had a story on our show a couple months ago about a guy who tried this and lasted only three days. That's actually what made the story interesting is that he quit so fast.
一些朋友写并演奏了原创音乐。这就是你们在节目中会听到的音乐。我喜欢它的一点是，你真的能感受到横穿美国是什么样的。几个月前，我们节目讲过一个试图这样做的人，但他只坚持了三天。那个故事之所以有趣，正是因为他放弃得太快了。
But Andrew did the whole thing, walked the whole country. His rule on the trip was no rides. He'd walk.
但安德鲁全程走完了，走遍了整个国家。他旅途中的规矩是不搭车。他要靠步行。
OK, so October 14, 2011, having my last breakfast at home. I feel my chest right now just racing. How do you feel, Mom?
好吧，2011年10月14日，我在家吃最后一顿早餐。我现在感觉心跳加速。你感觉如何，妈妈？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm mad at you. I feel like I'm being blown open again, like when you were born. So something big is happening. You're taking risks.
我生你的气。我觉得自己又被撕开了，就像你出生时那样。有大事要发生了。你在冒险。
No, I feel that.
不，我感觉到了。
And it's something-- and we-- you know. Oh, man. You're working me hard.
而且这……而且我们……你知道的。天哪。你真让我操心。
I walked out my back door that day with a 50 pound backpack, a mandolin, and a sign that said, walking to listen. I was on the train tracks. And about a half mile from my house, a car pulled off on the side of the road nearby. It was Bob, our landlord. I couldn't believe the coincidence.
那天我背着50磅重的背包，带着曼陀林琴，举着一块写着“徒步为了聆听”的牌子，走出了后门。我在铁轨上走。离家大约半英里时，一辆车停在路边。那是我们的房东鲍勃。我简直不敢相信这巧合。
It's not a coincidence, he said. Your mom's a wreck back at the house. You don't have to do this.
这不是巧合，他说。你妈妈在家里伤心欲绝。你不必这么做。
When I told him I was going to keep walking, he pulled a big knife out of his pocket and gave it to me. Don't trust anybody, he said.
当我告诉他我会继续走下去时，他从口袋里掏出一把大刀递给我。别相信任何人，他说。
Seven miles later, I saw some guys on the train tracks up ahead. There was no one else in sight, not even in shouting distance. I felt Bob's knife in my pocket.
七英里后，我看到前方铁轨上有几个人。视线范围内没有其他人，连呼喊声都传不到。我摸着口袋里鲍勃给的刀。
They were four Latino men. And when I got to them, they looked me up and down and asked what I was doing. I told them I was walking across America, which sounded ridiculous because I'd been walking for about two hours. But they gave me apple juice and cookies. And when I played a song for them on the mandolin, they gave me some vodka, too.
那是四个拉丁裔男人。当我走到他们身边时，他们打量了我一番，问我在做什么。我告诉他们我在徒步横穿美国，这听起来很荒谬，因为我才走了大约两个小时。但他们给了我苹果汁和饼干。当我用曼陀林琴为他们演奏了一首歌时，他们还给了我一些伏特加。
Well, Martin, new friends.
好吧，马丁，新朋友。
Yeah, new friends.
是啊，新朋友。
New friends.
新朋友。
Out of nowhere, it started raining on us. And the one named Martin said I could come with them to escape the storm. I thought, what the hell. Why not? I'm walking across America.
突然间，下起了雨。那个叫马丁的人说我可以跟他们一起躲雨。我想，管他呢。为什么不呢？我正在横穿美国。
I followed them into the woods. And their camp was behind a shopping center I'd been to a lot. We waited out the rain in the shacks they had built there.
我跟着他们走进树林。他们的营地在我经常去的购物中心后面。我们在他们搭建的小棚子里避雨。
When it cleared up, the men gave me some home grown chilies and cactus fruit. Martin shook my hand. God bless you, he said, and be careful. Sleep with a knife by your side.
雨停后，他们给了我一些自种的辣椒和仙人掌果。马丁跟我握了握手。上帝保佑你，他说，小心点。睡觉时把刀放在身边。
I am in Rising Sun, Maryland. Day two. My legs, my hips feel as if they have some sort of hot iron in them. I've got ungodly blisters on both heels now.
我在马里兰州的旭日镇。第二天。我的腿，我的臀部感觉好像塞进了什么热铁块。我现在的脚后跟上长了可怕的水泡。
I was on the highway, the only person in sight who was not in a car. But it was just-- you know. I was in a place where it felt like no one else was. Oh, wow. What am I doing? What am I doing?
我在高速公路上，视线范围内唯一一个不在车里的人。但这只是……你知道的。我在一个感觉不到其他人的地方。哦，天哪。我在做什么？我在做什么？
If you could go back and, taking all of what you've learned in your life, tell your 23-year-old self something, what might you say? What might be one of--
如果你能回到过去，带着你一生所学的一切，告诉23岁的自己一些事情，你会说什么？那会是什么——
Yeah, I wouldn't worry so much. I used to worry myself to death. And then now I realize the things you worry about, how many of them come true? Very seldom.
是的，我不会那么担心。我以前总把自己愁死。现在我意识到，那些你担心的事，有多少成了真？很少。
I'd go barefoot more. I wouldn't be nice. I wouldn't be the nice little Southern girl. I'd be a bitch.
我会更多地赤脚走路。我不会那么善良。我不会做那个善良的南方小姑娘。我会当个泼妇。
All right.
好吧。
I wasn't passive aggressive. I was just passive.
我以前不是消极抵抗。我只是消极。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
All right, you all want to do [INAUDIBLE]?
好，你们想做[听不清]吗？
Yeah, sounds good.
好，听起来不错。
When you're walking across the country, you get a lot of questions. Where do you sleep? And what do you eat? How much money do you have? What are you carrying? Are you taking rides or walking the whole way? Why are you walking?
当你徒步横穿全国时，你会遇到很多问题。你睡哪儿？你吃什么？你有多少钱？你带着什么？你是搭车还是全程步行？你为什么要走路？
So for the record, I planned as little as possible. Although I never expected it, most of the time somebody would offer to put me up for the night. When that didn't happen, I slept outside, under bridges or in the woods, wherever no one would see me. I figured my $3,000 in savings would get me through a whole year if I didn't stay in hotels or eat in restaurants much.
所以，郑重说明，我尽可能少做计划。虽然我从未预料到，但大多数时候都会有人主动提出让我住一晚。如果没有，我就睡在外面，桥下或树林里，只要没人看见我的地方。我想如果我不去旅馆也不怎么在餐馆吃饭，我的3000美元积蓄足够支撑我一整年。
I had a food bag I kept stocked with jerky, tuna fish, and PB&J. But people cooked for me all the time. And I never ate so well.
我有个食物袋，里面装满了肉干、金枪鱼和花生果酱三明治。但人们经常为我做饭。我从来没吃过这么好的饭。
In my pack, I carried camping gear, my mandolin, an old laptop, a camera, and a recorder for taping interviews. Maps, no smartphone. My policy was not to take rides that would shorten the walk.
我的背包里装着野营装备、曼陀林琴、旧笔记本电脑、相机和用于采访录音的录音机。地图，没有智能手机。我的原则是不搭车，因为那会缩短步行路程。
And as for why, well, I wanted to listen. After all, I was wearing a sign that said, walking to listen. And people told me about their lives, what they'd done, what they wish they'd done, whatever they thought I needed to hear. In Louisiana, a guy who let me camp out behind his trailer told me, all you're doing is reading a book, just with your feet.
至于原因，嗯，我想听。毕竟，我背着一块写着“徒步为了聆听”的牌子。人们告诉我他们的生活，他们做过的事，他们希望做过的事，任何他们认为我需要听到的事。在路易斯安那州，一个让我睡在他拖车后面的人对我说，你所做的就是在阅读一本书，只是用你的脚在读。
I just want to raise him to-- I mean, if he wants to play sports, play sports. If he wants to sit there and be like me, a mechanic, welder, whatever, hey, I'm not going to sit you and force you into something you're not-- you don't want. Why?
我只想把他抚养到——我的意思是，如果他想玩运动，就玩运动。如果他想像我一样坐着，当个机械师、焊工，什么都行，嘿，我不会强迫你去做你不想做的事情。为什么？
Do you have any fears as a parent?
你作为父母有什么恐惧吗？
Honestly, no. Take it day by day. I mean, would you have fears?
老实说，没有。过好每一天。我的意思是，你会有恐惧吗？
I think, for me, in some ways, maybe it's kind of like this walk. It's like, I had a lot of fears before. But now that I'm doing it, I don't have too many fears. I think it'd be the same if I have a kid.
我想，对我来说，在某些方面，也许就像这次徒步。就像，我以前有很多恐惧。但现在我在做了，我没那么多恐惧了。我想如果我有孩子也会一样。
Well, the thing about it is, you know, you find out you had a kid right now. It'd make you want to drop everything and go back home.
嗯，关于这件事，你知道，你现在发现有了孩子。这会让你想放下一切回家。
That's cool, man. Part of me feels happy doing what I'm doing. But it's not how I want to spend my life. Like I want--
这很酷，伙计。我的一部分感觉做我正在做的事很开心。但这不是我想度过余生的方式。比如我想要——
Doing what?
做什么？
Just living alone, kind of wandering, searching, traveling. I love it all. But it feels, in the end, a little bit empty.
只是独自生活，某种程度上的徘徊、寻找、旅行。我热爱这一切。但到头来，感觉有点空虚。
Oh, it is. But you know, after you've done walked this whole way, and have met different people, and learned so much about everything, and then took in all this knowledge, at the end, it's going to make you a different person. Everything that everybody tells you, it might be able to help you out to become this person-- a better father, a better husband, whatever.
哦，确实。但你知道，当你走完了整条路，遇到了不同的人，学到了关于一切的知识，吸收了所有这些智慧后，到最后，这会让你变成一个不同的人。每个人告诉你的每一件事，可能都能帮助你成为那个人——一个更好的父亲，更好的丈夫，或者别的什么。
Walking, walking, walking, walking, walking. Here's a little lumber truck. The lumber trucks have been zooming by on this road. It's a tiny, narrow little road. Oh, two cars now. All right. Got a honk. That is awesome.
走路，走路，走路，走路，走路。这是一辆小木材卡车。木材卡车在这条路上飞驰而过。这是一条又窄又小的小路。哦，现在有两辆车。好了。按喇叭了。那真是太棒了。
He was driving the Humvee. And there was a roadside bomb, or IED. He got the worst of it. He was kind of like a cool dude. So he would drive with his leg propped up on the steering wheel, just cruisin'.
他当时开着悍马。路上有个路边炸弹，或者说简易爆炸装置。他伤得最重。他是个很酷的家伙。他会把腿搁在方向盘上开车，优哉游哉的。
And I guess when it blew up, his leg gotten tangled. And in his words, it was like a noodle. When he woke up, it was completely backwards and flopped over his shoulder. But eventually, a year and a half later, infection set in. So he ended up having to amputate.
我猜当爆炸发生时，他的腿被缠住了。用他的话来说，就像面条一样。当他醒来时，那条腿完全反转过来，搭在他肩膀上。但最终，一年半后，感染发生了。所以他最后不得不截肢。
He was the life of the party. And even when I was 13, that was what attracted me to him, because I just felt like, you know, I was new. You have this person that has all these friends. And he just seemed so happy and bouncy. And he was just great.
他曾是聚会的焦点。甚至当我13岁时，这也是吸引我的原因，因为我觉得，你知道，我是新来的。你身边有个朋友很多的人。他看起来总是那么快乐、充满活力。他真的很好。
And when he came back, it was like slowly but surely, you could just see his soul almost being sucked out of him, if it hadn't been already. Because he started out fairly optimistic about his injuries. But eventually, we had been in and out of hospitals for years because it just wasn't ending.
当他回来时，就像慢慢地，你能感觉到他的灵魂几乎被抽干了，如果之前还没被抽干的话。因为他最初对自己的伤势相当乐观。但最终，我们多年来一直在医院进进出出，因为这似乎没完没了。
And he started to get mean. And he didn't care about much anymore. He wouldn't bathe for weeks.
他开始变得刻薄。他不再在乎任何事情。他可以几周不洗澡。
He started getting addicted to his pain medications that he was on all the time. And he just-- I don't know. It's like he got lost somewhere in Iraq and never really came back.
他开始沉迷于他一直服用的止痛药。他只是——我不知道。好像他在伊拉克丢了什么，再也没真正回来过。
And when he first died, all I could do when I first found out about it after realizing it had even happened-- because I had talked to him the night before. And everything sounded good. He sounded like he was getting things together. And everything was going to maybe get better. And finally a little ounce of hope.
当他第一次去世时，我发现这件事后，我能做的只有——因为前一天晚上我还跟他谈过。一切听起来都不错。他听起来好像正要把事情处理好。一切似乎都在好转。终于有了一点希望。
And then, I found out he died. Didn't really believe it. Once I did, the next day, I was at my friend's condo. And I just sat out in the sun, no sunscreen or anything. I just laid there and was hoping that the wind was him, or the bird flying by was him. And I was trying to-- hopefully, he would hear me, because I just felt like I had to say I'm sorry. Sorry.
然后，我发现他死了。真的不敢相信。一旦我相信了，第二天，我在朋友的公寓里。我就坐在阳光下，没有擦防晒霜什么的。我只是躺在那儿，希望风是他，或者飞过的鸟是他。我试图——希望他能听到我，因为我觉得我必须说对不起。对不起。
And there's a part of me that's like, why did he have to suffer for so long? And why did we have to treat each other the way that we did?
我心里的一部分会想，为什么他必须遭受那么久的痛苦？为什么我们必须那样对待彼此？
Like why couldn't it have just ended in Iraq? And he would have been a hero. And we wouldn't have all these crazy times, like all these struggles that didn't have to be there. I just didn't understand.
比如为什么不能就结束在伊拉克？那样他会是个英雄。我们就不会经历所有这些疯狂的时光，像所有这些本不必存在的挣扎。我只是不明白。
So yeah, I had a lot of guilt. But I've come to terms with it for the most part. Because again, I just feel like there's only so much you can do. And someone dying doesn't change that. It doesn't make them perfect.
所以是的，我有很多内疚感。但在很大程度上我已经接受了。因为再说一次，我觉得一个人能做的有限。有人去世并不能改变这一点。这不会让他们变得完美。
After everything, there is a part of me that's kind of shut off a little bit, because there's a tiny fear. It's like the more people I get close to, the closer I get to someone, if they were to die, I would just hurt all over again. I know that's so morbid.
经过这一切，我的一部分有点封闭了，因为有一点小小的恐惧。就像我越是接近某人，如果他们去世了，我会再次受到伤害。我知道这听起来很病态。
But on a day to day basis, I just try to appreciate things. You know, if I want to meet someone on the side of the road, I'm just going to do it. If I want to go somewhere, I just try to appreciate everything.
但每天，我只是尽量去欣赏事物。你知道，如果我想在路边遇见某人，我就去见。如果我想去什么地方，我只是尝试去欣赏一切。
If you care about someone, tell them. Don't leave anything behind that you wouldn't want someone to see if you were to die. There's so many little lessons. But I don't now.
如果你关心某人，告诉他们。别留下任何如果你去世后不想让人看见的东西。有很多小教训。但我不知道。
I don't know what the big life lesson is. But I definitely know to think before I speak. And when I talk to people, keep in mind that I might not talk to them again. And is that what I want to leave them with or them to leave me with? I don't know.
我不知道人生最大的教训是什么。但我绝对知道三思而后行。当我与人交谈时，记住我可能再也不会和他们说话了。这就是我想留给他们的，或者他们留给我的吗？我不知道。
I loved the South-- the swamps and the farmland, getting called baby and sugar at the diners. It was winter. But the cold wasn't too bad. And people were taking me in all the time. It seemed like every day there was some moment of grace.
我热爱南方——沼泽和农田，在餐馆里被叫作“宝贝”和“甜心”。那是冬天。但寒冷并不太难受。人们总是收留我。似乎每天都有某种恩典的时刻。
There was another side, too, though. A woman in Georgia told me I shouldn't walk through the next town because the whites had left, the help had stayed. And the southern black was a whole different animal than the northern black. Those were the words she used.
不过，也有另一面。佐治亚州的一位妇女告诉我，我不应该穿过下一个城镇，因为白人都离开了，留下的都是帮佣。而且南方的黑人和北方的黑人是完全不同的物种。那是她用的词。
This would happen a lot, people warning me about those others. They're not friendly like us. They'll shoot you for the shirt off your back. Don't trust them.
这种情况经常发生，人们警告我关于“那些人”。他们不像我们这么友好。他们会为了脱下你背上的衬衫而开枪打死你。别相信他们。
I never knew how to deal with the prejudice, especially when it came from someone who took me into their home and fed me. More often than I'd like to admit, I wouldn't say anything. And I still feel ashamed of that.
我从来不知道该如何处理这种偏见，尤其是当它来自一个把我带进家里并喂养我的人时。我不得不承认，很多时候我保持沉默。我至今仍为此感到羞耻。
What I wish is that these people could've experienced what I did, and seen that the people they warned me about were the very ones who took me in later on, and fed me, and told me their stories.
我的愿望是，这些人能经历我所经历的一切，看到他们警告我的人，正是后来收留我、喂养我并告诉我他们故事的人。
So what was it like back in the old days?
那么过去的日子是什么样的？
Oh god, honey. I've done got old and forgetful. And I've done forgot I used to know about that stuff. But all I can tell you is it was scary.
天哪，亲爱的。我已经老了，健忘了。我已经忘记了那些我曾经知道的事情。但我只能告诉你，那很可怕。
I never will forget, we were picking butter beans. And we had picked a bag that was in the garden for a white man. And the wife told us to go bring in some water.
我永远不会忘记，我们在摘黄油豆。我们摘了一袋，那是给一个白人老爷在花园里准备的。他妻子叫我们去取些水。
And we got the buckets out of the kitchen and went sailing through the hole to the well. Got the buckets full. And when we got back to the steps, he said, you niggers, don't you all come back up those steps. Go and run in the house with that water to the kitchen. And we said, yes, sir.
我们从厨房拿出水桶，穿过那个洞去水井。打满了桶。当我们回到台阶前时，他说，你们这些黑鬼，不准再上那些台阶。带着水跑到屋后的厨房去。我们说，好的，先生。
Now what do you think about those people who are so mean and hateful? What do you feel about them?
那么，对于那些刻薄和充满仇恨的人，你怎么看？你对他们有什么感觉？
I feel like they ain't looking for a great day. I'm looking for a great day, you know, when I see my Jesus face to face. You don't do evil for evil.
我觉得他们不是在追求美好的一天。我正在追求美好的一天，你知道，当我面对面见到耶稣时。你不能以恶报恶。
They hate you all. You all love them. And I thought, how could I love somebody tell me, you nigger, don't you come back up them steps, go round the house?
他们恨你们所有人。你们所有人去爱他们。我想，我怎么能爱那些对我说“你这黑鬼，不准再上台阶，绕到屋后去”的人呢？
Now how could I love somebody, Lord? And he said, that's the rule. That's the golden rule. Love thy neighbor as thyself. And I got to do what he says. I've got to love them.
主啊，我怎么能爱那样的人呢？他说，那是规矩。那是黄金法则。爱邻如己。我必须听他的话。我必须爱他们。
I've been traveling, traveling. That's enough.
我一直在旅行，旅行。够了。
Oh, come on. Come on. No, no, no. That was good.
哦，别这样。别，别，别。那很好。
I can play this one.
我可以弹这个。
I saw my first mesa in April in central Texas. I couldn't believe it. I had walked into the West.
四月我在德克萨斯州中部看到了我人生中的第一座平顶山。我简直不敢相信。我已经走进西部了。
I bought a used baby stroller so I could push my pack instead of caring it. It looked strange. But this way, I could carry all the water I needed.
我买了一辆二手的婴儿车，这样我就能推着背包而不是背着它。看起来很奇怪。但这样一来，我就能携带我需要的所有水。
It was getting hot. And there were long stretches between towns now. But without a backpack on my shoulders, it felt like I could walk forever.
天越来越热。城镇之间的距离现在很长。但没有背包压在肩上，我觉得我可以永远走下去。
My friend gave me a hand crank radio. And I've been using it every once in a while. And I'm going to crank this baby up. There we go. So basically, there's one station. Yep. And that's all we got.
朋友给了我一个手摇收音机。我时不时地用一下。我要摇动这玩意儿。好了。基本上，只有一个电台。没错。这就是我们拥有的全部。
Through New Mexico and Arizona, I was walking 30, sometimes 40 miles a day. It was kind of magical to be so alone and tiny in this huge desert day after day.
穿过新墨西哥州和亚利桑那州，我每天步行30，有时40英里。那种日复一日在巨大的沙漠中如此孤独和渺小的感觉，简直太神奇了。
I would lose myself out there. And I kind of liked it. But when somebody did take me in, I felt human again.
我会在那儿迷失自我。我挺喜欢的。但当有人收留我时，我感到自己又像个人了。
So being an older man--
所以，作为一个上了年纪的人——
Thank you.
谢谢。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, I'll be an older man.
是的，我要做一个上了年纪的人。
And looking back, what's it like to look back? And you were saying before you can't do some of the things you used to be able to do.
回顾往事，回顾是什么感觉？你之前说过，有些你以前能做的事现在做不到了。
Oh yeah. It breaks my heart, too. To put your foot up in a stirrup and just step up on a horse, I can't do that anymore.
哦，是的。这也让我心碎。把脚放进马镫然后跨上马，我再也做不到了。
And it's embarrassing to lead a horse to a fence, and get up on the fence, and get on the horse. You know, I hate to give up my independence that way. Dependent upon a fence to get me on a horse, that's dumb.
而且把马牵到围栏边，爬上围栏，然后再上马，太尴尬了。你知道，我讨厌那样放弃我的独立性。依赖围栏让我上马，那太蠢了。
But I'm satisfied doing what I did, because I always tried to be the best hand in the pasture or the best hand in the pen. I could do the work. And I could pick sick cattle. And I could doctor them.
但我对自己所做的事很满足，因为我一直努力成为牧场里最好的帮手或围栏里最好的帮手。我能干活。我能挑出病牛。我能给它们治病。
But as far as wishing I could do it again, sure I do. I wish I didn't get old. I wish my body would do what I tell it to.
但说到希望再做一次，当然。我希望我没有变老。我希望我的身体能听我的使唤。
And the reason I ask is because, God willing, I'll be there someday, too.
我之所以问，是因为如果上帝保佑，总有一天我也会到那个年纪。
I understand. It hadn't been, I don't know, the day before yesterday or something, I was in my 20s. And it just goes by. Whenever you're young, and you're waiting to get 16 to get your driver's license, the years go by kind of like highline posts.
我明白。如果不是，我不知道，前天或者什么的，我还二十几岁呢。时光飞逝。当你年轻时，等着到16岁拿驾照，岁月就像电线杆一样一根根闪过。
And then you get that. And you get out, and you go to work, and all that stuff. And then they get a little faster. They get like fence posts. And then pretty soon, you get up to 65 years old. And things change in your life so much so drastically, of putting your feet where you want them and your body where it needs to be. It's gone.
然后你拿到了。然后你出来，工作，所有那些事。然后它们跑得快了一点。它们就像栅栏桩。很快，你就到了65岁。生活会发生剧烈的变化，想把脚放在想放的地方，想把身体放在需要的地方。都没了。
And time goes by like cross ties on a railroad track-- just tch-tch-tch-tch. These days are gone. So while you've got it, use it. Your mind, your strength, your agility, use it.
时光就像铁轨上的枕木一样流逝——只是哒哒哒哒。这些日子一去不返了。所以当你还拥有的时候，利用它吧。你的思想，你的力量，你的敏捷，利用它。
If I can call back forty years-- I'm looking forward to going to heaven. And I wouldn't want to go through all my youth again. But I miss what I could do. I miss it.
如果我能召回四十年——我很期待去天堂。但我不想再经历一遍所有的青春。但我怀念我能做到的事。我怀念它。
If I got 10 more years in me, that'll be plenty. I'll be 83. I don't want to live past 83.
如果我还有10年可活，那就足够了。我将83岁。我不想活过83岁。
I don't want to be where somebody has to take care of me or lead me around or slobbering all my belly in a restaurant somewhere from a stroke. I'd just, of course, fall. And I'd break my neck. I really would.
我不想成为那种需要别人照顾或领着到处走的人，或者是在餐馆里因为中风弄得满肚子流口水。我当然会摔倒。我会摔断脖子。我真的会。
So you come back through here 10 years from now, I might be around. I might not. If I ain't, it's all all right. I've had a good life. I know 23, 73 looks pretty old. That's 50 years difference, son. 50 years makes  a lot of difference. But I relate. I can remember 23.
所以10年后你再经过这儿，我可能还在。可能不在了。如果不在了，那也没关系。我度过了美好的一生。我知道23岁觉得73岁看起来很老。那是50年的差距，孩子。50年差别很大。但我能产生共鸣。我记得23岁。
Ho. It's amazing walking because I've never-- I'm just going to stop for a second.
嘿。走路太神奇了，因为我从来没有——我只是停一下。
Besides the wind, there is nothing, no sound. And when the wind dies down, it's complete silence, like nothing I've heard before. And it's incredible. I love it. It feels very freeing.
除了风，什么都没有，没有声音。当风平息时，是一片死寂，像我从未听过的一样。这真是太棒了。我喜欢。感觉非常自由。
You can sing as loud as you want. You can say whatever you want. You can pull your pants down and moon the wind. You can dance around and make a fool of yourself.
你可以尽情大声唱歌。你想说什么就说什么。你可以脱掉裤子对着风亮出屁股。你可以跳舞，把自己弄得像个傻瓜。
[NAVAJO] is one of those words that's really difficult to translate. It's really a condition in your mind. It is when you are balanced.
[纳瓦霍语]是那些非常难以翻译的词汇之一。这其实是你内心的一种状态。它是当你平衡的时候。
You're living your life in the way that you're supposed to be, that the good Lord, the creator, had meant you to be, who you are supposed to be. And that is what [NAVAJO] is.
你正在按照你应该有的方式生活，上帝，造物主，本来希望你成为的样子，你本来就应该是谁。这就是[纳瓦霍语]的意思。
It is the ultimate goal of what Navajo people strive for. And it's something I struggle with every day.
这是纳瓦霍人民追求的终极目标。这也是我每天都在努力做到的。
With you right now, it would be like, you look around you. Everything's happy. You might not have enough to drink. Your shoes might be worn out. But you, yourself, inside you, you're feeling well. And you're happy. That's what [NAVAJO] is.
就像你现在，你环顾四周。一切都是快乐的。你可能没有足够的饮料。你的鞋子可能磨损了。但你，你自己，在内心深处，你感觉很好。而且你很快乐。这就是[纳瓦霍语]的意思。
Hello. Hello. I'm camped out underneath a bridge in Nevada, just outside of Mesquite. This heat-- it's a totally different ball game than anything I've really had to deal with.
你好。你好。我露营在内华达州的一座桥下，就在梅斯基特外面。这种热度——比起我真正需要应对的一切，完全是另一回事。
Basically, it feels dangerous. I feel like I'm on the brink, you know? And I could either fall into that sense of calm. Or I could freak out.
基本上，感觉很危险。我觉得我正处于边缘，你知道吗？我可能陷入那种平静感。或者我可能惊慌失措。
I see how the desert does what it does to people. Because if I didn't have this water-- well, if I didn't have this water, that'd be a whole other story. ,But yeah, I can see how it could drive you a little nuts.
我看到了沙漠对人们做了什么。因为如果我没有这些水——好吧，如果我没有这些水，那将是另一个故事。但是的，我能看到它怎么能把你弄得有点疯狂。
I hit the wall in Nevada. It was near 110 degrees every day. So I started walking at night. I was sleep deprived and a little delirious.
我在内华达州遇到了瓶颈。每天气温接近110度。所以我开始在晚上走路。我睡眠不足，有点神志不清。
Very few people stopped on the road to say hello. They must have thought it was best to just keep driving when they saw a man pushing a baby carriage in the middle of the desert.
很少有人在路上停下来打招呼。他们一定认为，当看到一个男人在沙漠中央推着婴儿车时，最好还是继续开车。
There's all kinds of walking. There's float walking when it's the easiest thing in the world. And there's urge walking when you're just desperate to stop. There's high walking when you're high and hurt walking when you're hurt. I like weep walking the best, when all you can do is cry.
走路有各种各样的方式。有当它是世界上最简单的事情时那种“漂浮走”；有当你迫切想要停下来时那种“催促走”；有当你兴奋时那种“高走”，还有当你受伤时那种“伤痛走”。我最喜欢“哭泣走”，就是当你什么也做不了，只能哭的时候。
I was doing two types of walking at night in Nevada. The first was dream walking, which happens when everything seems like a hallucination. The second was fear walking.
我在内华达州的晚上做两种类型的走路。第一种是“梦幻走”，这发生在一切看起来都像幻觉的时候。第二种是“恐惧走”。
I almost got lost one night in a long stretch of desert outside Mesquite. I took a back road, which turned into a dirt trail. And it kept splitting into forks. I had no idea where I was on the map.
有天晚上我差点在梅斯基特外的一长段沙漠里迷路。我走了一条偏僻的小路，它变成了一条土路。而且它不断地分叉。我不知道自己在地图上的什么位置。
I was low on water. And when the sun came, there would be no shade. But I kept going down the dirt trail.
我水不够了。当太阳出来时，将没有遮荫处。但我还是沿着土路走下去。
Finally, it hit me. I could actually die out here. In fact, if I couldn't find my way back to the main road, I probably would.
最后，我意识到了。我真的可能会死在这里。事实上，如果我找不到回大路的路，我可能真的会死。
Before dawn, I managed to find the main road again. But I couldn't get it out of my head, the image of that desert trail winding into the darkness. From then on, I was fear walking.
黎明前，我设法找到了大路。但我无法把它从脑海中赶走，那条蜿蜒进黑暗中的沙漠小径的景象。从那时起，我就一直处于“恐惧走”中。
[TRAIN WHISTLE]
[火车鸣笛]
Whoo.
喔。
When I finally climbed up into the Sierras, I almost didn't believe it. There were trees and lakes. And the nights were actually cold.
当我终于爬上内华达山脉时，我几乎不敢相信。有树木和湖泊。晚上实际上很冷。
The ocean was 200 miles away. So I could count on two hands the number of days I had until the end. I expected to feel some sort of euphoria in the last two weeks of the walk. But it wasn't that at all. I was terrified, especially when I realized there was no escaping the end.
离大海还有200英里。所以我可以用两只手算出离终点还有多少天。我以为最后两周会有一种欣快感。但完全不是那样。我感到恐惧，特别是当我意识到终点是无法逃避的时候。
I've always known I'm going to die some day, like we all do. But I think it was only in the last two weeks of the walk that I really believed it.
我一直知道总有一天我会死，就像我们所有人一样。但我认为只有在走路的最后两周，我才真正相信这一点。
All the things people had been telling me about aging and grief and loss, someday my turn would actually come. And my turn with death would come, too. I had just turned 24. And death was as far away as the Pacific Ocean was from my home when I first started walking.
人们一直告诉我关于衰老、悲伤和失去的一切，总有一天会轮到我。死亡也终将降临。我刚满24岁。死亡就像我刚开始走路时太平洋离我的家一样遥远。
But someday I would get there, just like I was going to get to the ocean. I stopped recording audio and taking notes. I walked each day in a weepy daze of disbelief. This is it, I kept saying. This is it.
但总有一天我会到达那里，就像我终将到达海洋一样。我停止了录音和记笔记。我每天都在一种难以置信的泪眼朦胧中行走。这就是了，我不断重复。这就是了。
The last night I spent on the road, I was camped out in the forest 20 miles from the ocean. I set up the tent for the last time. And I ate my last dinner from the food bag.
我旅途中的最后一晚，是在离大海20英里的森林里露营。我最后一次搭起帐篷。我从食物袋里吃了最后一顿晚餐。
There were cars passing me on the road. And I had this thought, if I were in one of those cars right now looking into this dark forest, I'd probably think it was a scary place. But I'm in the forest. And I know it's not a scary place. In that moment, I didn't feel so afraid of the end.
路上有车经过。我产生了这样的想法：如果我现在在那辆车里看着这片黑暗的森林，我可能会认为这是一个可怕的地方。但我正身处森林中。我知道它不是一个可怕的地方。那一刻，我不那么害怕终点了。
On the afternoon of September 8, 2012, I saw the Pacific Ocean. An hour more of walking, and I was there on the beach. Mom was waiting for me and Dad was, too. And so many friends, all of them surrounding me in a big circle.
2012年9月8日下午，我看到了太平洋。又走了一个小时，我就在海滩上了。妈妈在等我，爸爸也在等我。还有很多朋友，他们都围成一个大圈。
Even some people I'd met along the way mad it. The men from Navajo country drove from the reservation. And they led me to the water, drumming and singing a chant. And I was weep walking.
甚至有些我在路上遇到的人也赶来了。纳瓦霍地区的人们从保护区开车过来。他们领我走向水边，敲着鼓，唱着歌。我当时正处于“哭泣走”中。
I was in the water. I was floating in this dream. And there were so many voices, 4,000 miles of them.
我在水里。我漂浮在这个梦境中。有太多的声音，4000英里的声音。
It's been six months since the ocean and the end. I'm not walking anymore, or not like that. And so sometimes I find myself forgetting everything the walk was to me. When I listen, though, I remember. And then I forget again.
离海洋和终点已经过去六个月了。我不再走路了，至少不是那样走路了。所以有时我发现自己忘记了这段路程对我意味着什么。但当我倾听时，我记起来了。然后我又忘了。
When I was on the road, I loved asking people what they'd say to their 23-year-old self if they could go back in time. I would tell myself three things. You know exactly what to do. There's no need to be afraid. Keep walking.
在路上时，我喜欢问人们，如果能回到过去，他们会对23岁的自己说什么。我会告诉自己三件事。你完全知道该做什么。没有必要害怕。继续走下去。
Andrew Forsthoefel. He spent 11 months on the road, wore through five pairs of shoes, spend a little less than $1,000. He's now writing a book about the trip.
安德鲁·福斯特霍费尔。他在路上待了11个月，穿坏了五双鞋，花了不到1000美元。他现在正在写一本关于这次旅行的书。
He produced the radio story with Jay Allison, thanks to Viki Merrick. An hour long version of the story and photos of the trip are at transom.org. transom.org is a free, nonprofit website that explains how to record and produce your own stories.
他与杰·艾利森制作了这个广播故事，感谢维基·梅里克。该故事的一小时版本和旅行照片在transom.org。transom.org是一个免费的非营利网站，解释了如何录制和制作你自己的故事。
Coming up, two more road trips. And they are nothing like Andrew's. They are in cars, one with a lady who's about to give birth, one with the kid who really, really, really needs to pee. We floor it. And we do not stop for anything, in one minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，还有两次公路旅行。它们和安德鲁的完全不同。它们是在车里，一个和一个即将分娩的女士在一起，一个和一个真的、真的、真的需要小便的孩子在一起。我们全速前进。我们不会为任何事情停下，一分钟后。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Hit the Road," stories of heading out into the unknown during the time in your life when it means the most, specifically when you are still figuring out who you are. We have arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, Car Pool.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，“踏上旅程”，关于在人生中意义最重大的时期——特别是当你还在摸索自己是谁的时候——走向未知的旅程的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，拼车。
The actual distance covered by the car in this next story is not very far. But as you'll hear, the kid in the car really cares about how things work out. It was recorded by Sierra Teller-Ornelas in front of a live audience. She changed some of the names in this story.
在接下来的故事中，车子实际行驶的距离并不远。但如你所听到的，车里的孩子非常在意事情的发展。它是由谢拉·泰勒-奥内拉斯在现场观众面前录制的。她在故事中更改了一些名字。
Hello, everybody. Can you hear me OK? Awesome. Before I start, [NAVAJO].
大家好。你们能听清我说话吗？太棒了。在我开始之前，[纳瓦霍语]。
I'm Navajo. And it is traditional in our culture to begin by alienating the entire audience. So you're welcome.
我是纳瓦霍人。在我们文化中，开始时先疏远整个听众是传统。所以，不客气。
So I was born and raised in Tucson, Arizona. What up? When I was around 11, I lived in this apartment complex called Christopher City, which was like a dorm for families.
我是在亚利桑那州图森市出生长大的。怎么样？我11岁左右时，住在一家叫克里斯托弗城的公寓大楼，就像一个家庭宿舍。
My dad was in college. And it was mostly international students who brought their families. So my neighbors were from Korea, the Middle East, Japan, all over. And then it was also single moms who couldn't live off campus, couldn't afford to.
我爸爸上大学时住在那儿。那里住的大多是带着家庭的国际学生。所以我邻居有韩国人、中东人、日本人，来自各地。还有一些无法住校外、负担不起的单身妈妈。
So get home from school one day. And my mom is like, get ready. You're going out.
有一天放学回家。我妈妈说，准备好。你要出去了。
And I was like, who am I going out with? And she was like, my friend Jeanette, who had just moved into town, wants to take you to a baseball game, AAA, Tucson Toros, pretty exciting.
我问，我要跟谁出去？她说，我的朋友珍妮特，刚搬到城里，想带你们去看棒球比赛，AAA级，图森公牛队，很令人兴奋。
And I was like, wait a minute. And she's going to take her daughter, Candace, and her new boyfriend, Ahmed. And I was like, Candace Simms?
我心想，等等。她还要带她女儿坎迪斯和她的新男朋友艾哈迈德。我问，坎迪斯·西姆斯？
And Candace Simms was like the coolest girl. She had just moved into town. And she was just wild. She would flip off the teachers when they were writing, and you couldn't see.
坎迪斯·西姆斯可是最酷的女孩。她刚搬到镇上。她非常野。老师写字时她会给老师竖中指，而且你还看不见。
And she wore nail polish. And she claimed to do downstairs stuff with guys. And she cursed. And it was just amazing.
她涂指甲油。而且她声称和男生做些越轨的事。她还骂人。那真是太棒了。
I was like, oh my god, this is my chance. I'm going to be best friends with Candace Simms. This could happen. I just need to be around her. And I had a plan.
我心想，天哪，机会来了。我要和坎迪斯·西姆斯成为最好的朋友。这完全可能发生。我只需要在她身边。我有一个计划。
And so my mom was like, well, the plan was that you're going to go to this game. Then you're going to come spend the night at my house. And then tomorrow, you're going to go to Shandy Castelary's pool party.
所以我妈说，嗯，计划是你们去看比赛。然后你要去我家过夜。第二天，你要去珊迪·卡斯特拉里的泳池派对。
And so I was like, this is the dream. When you're 10, that's like an 8-ball worth of fun. It doesn't get any better.
我心想，这简直是梦。当你10岁时，那简直是8号球（意指极度）的乐趣。没有比这更好的了。
So I go. And it becomes immediately clear that the motivations that we all had were very different. Mine was clear, make Candace my best friend.
所以我去了。很快就很清楚，我们每个人的动机非常不同。我的很清楚，让坎迪斯成为我最好的朋友。
Jeanette was sort of constantly trying to find Mr. Can You Pay Half the Rent. She was just an exhausted single mom. She just wanted to get married.
珍妮特一直试图寻找那位“先生，你能付一半房租吗”。她只是一个筋疲力尽的单身妈妈。她只想结婚。
And then Ahmed was this guy from Iran, nice enough. The long con was probably like a green card marriage. But the short con was definitely just [BLEEP] Jeanette, you know?
艾哈迈德是来自伊朗的一个家伙，人还可以。长远图谋可能是绿卡婚姻，但短期图谋绝对只是想和珍妮特[脏话]，你知道的？
And he could not have hated us more. He was so disinterested in me and Candace, which I don't totally blame him for. Because every time he would be like, would you like a hot dog? I would be like, yes, whereas Candace would be like, [BLEEP] you, Ahmed. I [BLEEP] think you have AIDS.
他简直不能更讨厌我们了。他对我和坎迪斯毫无兴趣，我对他也没什么可抱怨的。因为每次他问，“你们想吃热狗吗？”，我都会回答“想”，而坎迪斯会说，“去你的，艾哈迈德。我觉得你有艾滋病。”
And we'd just be like holy [BLEEP], because I had never heard a little girl talk like that. But she didn't have a lot of parenting. It wasn't a two parent home.
我们只会想，老天，因为我从未听过一个小女孩那样说话。但她父母没怎么管她。那不是一个双亲家庭。
So anyway, the mom was just sort of like, I could marry a pharmacist. So she threw $20 at us. And we left, and drank a bunch of soda and ate a bunch hot dogs and enjoyed the game.
总之，那个妈妈只是觉得，我能嫁给一个药剂师。所以她扔给我们20美元。我们走了，喝了很多汽水，吃了很多热狗，很享受比赛。
So we get back into Ahmed's car. And we're driving home. And I'm like, OK, Tuscon Toros were a bust. But we got the sleep over. We got the pool party. This is going to be awesome.
我们坐回艾哈迈德的车里。我们在开车回家。我心想，好吧，图森公牛队表现不佳。但我们有留宿。我们有泳池派对。这会很棒的。
And it becomes clear that Ahmed doesn't know how to get back to the apartment complex. And so he starts going around and around. But Jeanette, being like the woman, doesn't want emasculate him. So she doesn't give him directions. And then it just is clear that he's lost. And he's frustrated.
而且很明显，艾哈迈德不知道怎么回到公寓大楼。所以他开始绕来绕去。但珍妮特，作为一个女性，不想让他显得没面子。所以她不给他指路。很明显他迷路了。而且他很沮丧。
And so from the back, Candace just starts doing this impression where it's like, I am Ahmed. I eat lentils. I don't know where I'm going. That was her, by the way. It was not me. No offense to the Middle Eastern community.
于是从后座，坎迪斯开始模仿他，就像是：我是艾哈迈德。我吃扁豆。我不知道要去哪儿。顺便说一下，那是她，不是我。对中东社区没有冒犯的意思。
And now I feel super bad for this poor guy. But when you're 10, that is the funniest [BLEEP] you've ever heard. I could not stop laughing.
现在我为这个可怜的家伙感到超级内疚。但在10岁时，那是你听过的最搞笑的事情。我忍不住大笑。
I laughed so hard. And I was trying so badly to stifle it. And I laughed so hard that I relieved 64 ounces of Pepsi all over Ahmed's Tercel.
我笑得太厉害了。我拼命想要抑制住。我笑得把64盎司的百事可乐全都尿在了艾哈迈德的特赛尔车里。
And between the screaming and the impressions and Jeanette, nobody noticed. It was nighttime. And so I'm like, all right. All right, this has happened.
在尖叫声、模仿声和珍妮特之间，没人注意到。那是晚上。所以我心想，好吧。好吧，这已经发生了。
And I was peeing-- it was like minutes. I mean, it was so long that I went on a journey. I went from like shock to that ecstasy of how good it feels to pee to shame, and then back to the ecstasy, and then rounded out with some shame. It was just so bad.
我尿的时候——足足有好几分钟。我的意思是，尿的时间太长了，我经历了一场旅程。我从震惊，到尿出来感觉舒服的那种狂喜，再到羞耻，然后再回到那种狂喜，最后以一些羞耻结束。简直太糟了。
So I'm sitting there. And I'm like, OK, hope is not lost. I can make this work. And so from the darkness, I'm like, oh no, Ahmed. I just spilled Pepsi on your car seat and my pants, like I was in some kind of commercial for a detergent that worked on clothing and upholstery.
我坐在那儿，心想，好吧，还没失去希望。我能补救。于是从黑暗中，我说，哦不，艾哈迈德。我刚才把百事可乐洒在你的车座和我的裤子上了，就像我处于某种清洁剂的广告里，那种对衣服和坐垫都有效的广告。
And it just was bad. I didn't have a cup. I had no props to support my assertion. He immediately called me out.
情况很糟。我没有杯子。我没有任何道具来支持我的说法。他立刻拆穿了我。
He flipped on the light. And he looked back while driving. And he like flipped out, because he had been white knuckle driving this whole time. He'd kept it all in.
他打开灯。他在开车时往后看。他简直疯了，因为他刚才一直憋着这股火。他一直忍着。
And he was like, you pee in my car. You pee in my car, you dirty American.
他说，你在我的车里尿了。你在我的车里尿了，你这个肮脏的美国人。
And I was like, no I didn't. No I didn't.
我说，不我没有。我没有。
He's like, you are a car-peer, in exactly the same accent that Candace had been doing like three minutes ago. So I lose my [BLEEP] again. And I'm laughing uncontrollably.
他说，你是个车里尿尿的家伙，语气和坎迪斯三分钟前模仿的一模一样。所以我又失控了。我笑得停不下来。
It's a tough break, guys. So he pulls into Christopher City. I bolt to my mom's house. Obviously Candace is not spending the night.
真倒霉，伙计们。他把车开进克里斯托弗城。我冲向我妈妈家。显然坎迪斯没留下过夜。
And the next morning, my mom is like, well you gotta go to this pool party. And I'm like, oh no. I am a car-peer. That is what I am. Car-peers do not get to go to pool parties. They stay home and die alone.
第二天早上，我妈说，你要去那个泳池派对。我心想，哦不。我是个车里尿尿的家伙。我就是。车里尿尿的家伙是不准去泳池派对的。他们待在家里孤独地死去。
But my mom was like, well, I may plans. So you're going to this [BLEEP] party. So I go. And I show up.
但我妈说，我计划好了。所以你要去那个[脏话]派对。所以我去了。我到了。
And I'm just like, this is my life. She's going to tell everybody. She's the popular girl at school.
我只是想，这就是我的人生。她会告诉所有人的。她是学校里的受欢迎女孩。
And I get there. And she comes up to me. And before I could say I'm sorry, she was like, that was amazing.
我到了那儿。她朝我走来。在我道歉之前，她说，那太棒了。
For her, it was like the most baller move I could do. He freaking was sopping up for two hours. Dude didn't get any play. And thanks to her hatred for Ahmed, I was only a car-peer for one night. So thank you.
对她来说，那简直是我能做的最屌的事情。那家伙擦了两个小时的坐垫。那家伙没捞到任何好处。多亏了她对艾哈迈德的厌恶，我只当了一晚上的“车里尿尿的家伙”。所以谢谢你。
Sierra Teller-Ornelas is a TV writer in Los Angeles. Her performance was recorded at the LA Storytelling Series, Public School. Their website publicschool.com. It also aired on the CBC radio show WireTap with Jonathan Goldstein, which can be found at cbc.ca/wiretap.
谢拉·泰勒-奥内拉斯是洛杉矶的电视编剧。她的表演是在洛杉矶故事讲述系列“公立学校”录制的。他们的网站publicschool.com。它也在乔纳森·戈德斯坦的CBC广播节目《WireTap》中播出，可以在cbc.ca/wiretap找到。
ACT 3, Let's See How Fast This Baby Can Go? So let's close on this story about hitting the road and needing to hit the road for a straightforward, maybe even a traditional kind of reason, to change every single thing in your life. This story is from Gloria Harrison.
第三幕，让我们看看这宝贝能跑多快？所以让我们以这个关于踏上旅程、为了一个直白甚至可以说是传统的原因——去改变生活中每一件事——而需要踏上旅程的故事结束吧。这个故事来自格洛丽亚·哈里森。
I wake up before 7 o'clock on the morning of Tuesday, June 4, 1996. And I know three things instantly. I'm in labor. I have to return the car to that awful man. And I have to go buy another car. If I don't, I won't have any way to get myself to the hospital. I am 20 years old.
1996年6月4日星期二早上7点前我醒了。我立刻知道三件事。我要生了。我必须把车还给那个可怕的男人。我必须去买另一辆车。如果我不这么做，我就没法去医院。我20岁。
The pain in my belly and lower back is intense. And I flop over onto my knees and bounce up and down, which wakes up my roommate, Tim, who sort of doubles as my boyfriend.
我的腹部和下背部的疼痛非常强烈，我跪倒在地上下弹跳，吵醒了我的室友蒂姆，他同时也兼任我的男朋友。
"I'm in labor," I tell him. "Are you sure," he asks, having just spent the last week listening to me declare the same concern regularly. Tim's on standby, as is my sister, Kim, who has a flight arranged from Kansas City. The moment she hears word that I'm at the hospital delivering, she will grab her packed luggage and the diaper bag she's had waiting probably since the moment I agreed to let her and her new husband adopt my child.
“我要生了，”我告诉他。“你确定吗？”他问，他过去一周听我定期宣布同样的担忧。蒂姆随时待命，我的妹妹金也是，她已经从堪萨斯城安排了航班。她一听到我在医院分娩的消息，就会立刻拿起行李和她准备好的尿布袋——大概从我同意让她和新婚丈夫领养我的孩子那一刻起她就准备好了。
"Yes, I'm sure," I tell Tim. "I'm going to go buy a car." He considers me through half opened eyes for a moment, says, "OK," then rolls back over and goes back to sleep.
“是的，我很确定，”我告诉蒂姆。“我要去买车。”他半睁着眼睛打量了我一会儿，说了声“好吧”，然后翻了个身又睡着了。
The first order of business is to return the used car that I picked up the day before. My contractions are about 10 minutes apart.
第一要务是把前一天刚取到的那辆旧车还回去。我的宫缩间隔大约是10分钟。
I discovered that I'd contracted an acute case of pregnancy within two weeks of moving to Albuquerque from Dallas, where I'd lived for the last five months. I made the decision to place the baby up for adoption not long after, having found myself homeless and broke and with no one to turn to.
我发现自己怀孕是在从达拉斯搬到阿尔伯克基后的两周内，我在达拉斯住了五个月。搬来不久我就决定把孩子送人领养，因为我发现自己无家可归、身无分文，没有可以求助的人。
I told my family that I wouldn't be keeping him. And within a week, my sister Kim called and asked if she and her husband could adopt him. She was 22 and had been married for three weeks. "Of course," I said, relieved.
我告诉家人我不打算留下孩子。一周之内，我妹妹金打电话问她和她丈夫是否可以领养他。她22岁，结婚才三周。“当然，”我说，松了一口气。
Seven months later, I am no longer broke or homeless. On Christmas day, I walked into a fast food restaurant and told them I needed a job. They hired me on the spot.
七个月后，我不再身无分文或无家可归了。圣诞节那天，我走进一家快餐店，告诉他们我需要一份工作。他们当场录用了我。
I met Tim there. And he and I found an apartment together soon after. Neither of us had a car.
我在那儿遇到了蒂姆。不久后我们就在一起找了间公寓。我们谁也没有车。
A week ago, I received a large portion of a $50,000 insurance settlement in the mail, my in-pocket amount from a lawsuit that has been ongoing since I was 17. I had to see multiple insurance companies, including the one belonging to the drunk with the 0.28 blood alcohol level who had crashed into my foster family's van nearly three years before.
一周前，我收到了5万美元保险赔偿金中的一大部分，这是我自17岁起一直在进行的一场诉讼中获得的赔偿。我不得不面对多家保险公司，包括那家属于那个醉驾的——血液酒精浓度0.28——几乎三年前撞进我寄养家庭货车的人的保险公司。
Three people died in the accident, which mangled the rest of us. I've also had to sue my foster dad, who had collected an upfront check for $25,000, which was supposed to go for my medical care.
那次事故中三个人死了，其余的人伤残严重。我还不得不起诉我的寄养爸爸，他收走了一张25,000美元的预付支票，这笔钱本应是我的医疗费。
He kicked me out a week later, despite the fact that I was on a walker and had nowhere to go. We settled. And he had to pay back $15,000 of the money he'd taken. The money came out of his personal account. When his check eventually arrived, the memo said, Gloria's blood money.
他一周后就把我赶了出来，尽管我当时还要拄着助行器，无处可去。我们达成了和解。他不得不退还他收走的15,000美元。这钱是从他的个人账户里出的。当他的支票最终寄到时，备注栏上写着：格洛丽亚的血钱。
I received my money a week ago. And I still haven't bought a car. All of the grown-ups in my life have an opinion about what kind of car I should drive. And I'm scared and not confident in my ability to make a decision.
我一周前收到了钱。但我还没买车。生活中所有的成年人对我要开什么车都有意见。我感到害怕，对自己的决定能力没信心。
And I actually really don't care. I just want mobility. Last night, at the behest of Tim's stepdad, I went to a car lot that sells used rental cars.
说实话，我其实根本不在乎。我只想要移动能力。昨晚，在蒂姆继父的要求下，我去了一个卖二手租赁车的地方。
The slimy salesman delivered his spiel to Tim, not me, even though I made it clear that I was the one with the money. Still, he barely looked at me, and instead locked eyes with Tim while he explained the great benefits of buying this great car with low miles at this unbelievable price.
那个油腻的销售员向蒂姆推销，而不是我，尽管我明确表示钱是我出的。尽管如此，他几乎没看我，而是盯着蒂姆的眼睛，向他解释买这辆里程数低、价格难以置信的车的好处。
I am not interested in this car. And I told the salesman that. "Tell you what," he said derisively, finally looking at me, "you just drive it home tonight, free of charge. And think about it."
我对这辆车没兴趣。我告诉了销售员。“这样吧，”他讽刺地说，最后看了我一眼，“你今晚就把车开回家吧，免费的。考虑一下。”
Now I have this burdensome car to deal with before I can buy my Nissan, which is what I have wanted from the start. Tim's stepdad was pushy and insistent about not buying a car new off the lot. And though I'm normally incapable of standing up for myself against aggressive men, I'm now currently in labor. And I feel a strength and self-composure I've never felt before. I don't want this [BLEEP] rental car. And I don't care who knows it.
现在，在我买到从一开始就想要的日产汽车之前，我得处理这辆碍事的车。蒂姆的继父对不买新车这件事强硬且坚持。虽然我通常无法在咄咄逼人的男人面前捍卫自己，但我现在正在分娩。我感到一种前所未有的力量和自制力。我不想要这辆[脏话]租赁车。我不在乎谁知道。
I drive the car over to the lot, which is conveniently located on the same boulevard as most of the car lots in town. I walk into the office, find the swaggering salesman, hand him the keys, and tell him I have changed my mind.
我把车开到那家店，正好位于镇上大部分车行所在的同一条大道上。我走进办公室，找到那个大摇大摆的销售员，把钥匙递给他，告诉他我改变主意了。
His mouth drops open. And incredulous, he frantically begins negotiating with me all over again. He stands too close and speaks too loudly. The contractions are coming more frequently now, perhaps seven minutes apart. And the urgency to take care of the business at hand fills me with confidence.
他惊得目瞪口呆。他怀疑地疯狂地试图和我重新谈判。他站得太近，说话太大声。宫缩现在越来越频繁了，可能间隔七分钟。那种处理手头事务的迫切感让我充满信心。
I tell him I have to go. I'm going down the street to the Nissan dealership to buy the car I wanted in the first place. I begin walking off the lot. And he shouts after me, "that car will lose $5,000 in value the second you drive it off the lot."
我告诉他我得走了。我要去街对面的日产经销店买我最初想要的那辆车。我开始离开车行。他在后面大喊：“那辆车你一开出车行，价值就会缩水5000美元。”
By 9 o'clock, I'm walking the two blocks to Melloy Nissan, telling myself that walking is good for labor. I enter the building and look around. I see a customer service window, walk up to it, and ask the representative, "Do you have a female salesperson?"
9点钟时，我步行两个街区到梅洛日产经销店，告诉自己走路对分娩有好处。我走进大楼环顾四周。我看到一个客户服务窗口，走过去问接待员：“你们有女销售员吗？”
A few minutes later, Carolyn walks up. I can tell right away that she's a nice lady. She makes eye contact with me, shakes my hand, and introduces herself. "Looks like you're due pretty soon, huh?" she says, gesturing towards my massive midsection. "Yes, today actually," I tell her "I'm in labor."
几分钟后，卡罗琳走了过来。我一眼就能看出她是个好心人。她看着我的眼睛，跟我握手，自我介绍。“看起来你快生了，是吧？”她指着我巨大的肚子说。“是的，实际上就是今天，”我告诉她，“我正在分娩。”
Next thing I know, Carolyn is showing me my options. I know that I want a Sentra. And I don't want any bells and whistles, just the basic package. This makes the decision easy. There are only two cars that meet my desires. And I just have to decide between teal and black.
接下来我知道的就是，卡罗琳在给我展示各种选择。我知道我想要一辆森特拉。我不想要任何花哨的功能，只要基本配置。这让决定变得简单。只有两辆车符合我的要求。我只需要在蓝绿色和黑色之间做决定。
I'm leaning toward black. But Carolyn explains that black cars are harder to keep clean since dirt shows up on them so easily. While we have this discussion, I am pacing in circles, holding my lower back and choo-chooing every few minutes.
我偏向黑色。但卡罗琳解释说，黑色车比较难保持清洁，因为灰尘在上面很容易显现。在讨论时，我绕着圈走，扶着下背部，每隔几分钟就喘气一次。
"Can I test drive it?" I ask. Carolyn looks and me, startled and uneasy. "Sure," she says. And within three minutes, she has the keys. And we're on our way in the teal car.
“我可以试驾吗？”我问。卡罗琳看着我，吃惊且不安。“当然，”她说。不到三分钟，她就拿到了钥匙。我们开着蓝绿色的车上路了。
We don't drive far. And to be honest, I'm not even sure why I want to test drive the car, other than, like always, I'm preemptively explaining myself to the overlords in my head. Test driving is something I understand is a necessary step in the car buying process. I know I'm buying this car. And I know I would buy it even if Carolyn had said no to taking it for a spin.
我们没开远。老实说，我甚至不知道自己为什么要试驾这辆车，除了像往常一样，我在预先向我脑子里的独裁者们解释自己。我知道试驾是买车过程中的必要步骤。我知道我要买这辆车。而且我知道就算卡罗琳拒绝我把它开出去试一圈，我也会买它。
Carolyn tries to chat me up while we're driving, asking me about my pregnancy and the father. "I'm putting it up for adoption," I tell her. Carolyn talks to me about this for the duration of the drive. And when I answer, my voice rises an octave each time I have a contraction.
开车时卡罗琳试图跟我闲聊，问我关于怀孕和孩子父亲的事。“我打算把它送人领养，”我告诉她。在驾驶过程中，卡罗琳一直跟我谈论这件事。而当我回答时，每次宫缩，我的声音都会升高一个八度。
Next thing I know, Carolyn and I are in her office. And there's paperwork in front of me. I have a checkbook to hold an account that holds nearly enough money to buy the car out right. But Carolyn is trying to finance the whole amount.
接下来，我和卡罗琳都在她的办公室里了。我面前有文件。我有一个支票簿，账户里有足够的钱直接买下这辆车。但卡罗琳试图让我贷款全额。
She explains that if they take a personal check, they have to hold it for a week until it clears. And I won't get my car today. My contractions are now about six minutes apart. And I know I have to get to the hospital. Banks are called. Documents are faxed.
她解释说，如果他们收个人支票，他们必须等待一周直到兑现。我今天就拿不到车了。我的宫缩现在大约间隔六分钟。我知道我必须去医院。银行被叫来。文件被传真。
A man comes in and tries to discuss floor mat options with me. I am highly agitated. And I stand up every few minutes to pace and pant.
一个男人进来试图跟我讨论脚垫的选择。我非常烦躁。我每隔几分钟就站起来踱步、喘气。
The frenzy of activity around me is intense. Suddenly all of the sales associates are in the room, each trying desperately to help the pregnant girl get the car bought before a head emerges from her vagina in the middle of the showroom floor.
周围活动的疯狂程度很剧烈。突然间所有的销售人员都在房间里，每个人都在拼命帮助这个孕妇买下车，以免在展厅地板中间有个脑袋从她阴道里冒出来。
Finally, my brain kicks into action. And I announce how it's going to be. I don't want to finance the whole amount. Even in my less than right mind, I know that 22% interest is a lot. And I just want to pay for as much as I can right there.
终于，我的大脑开始运作。我宣布了将要怎么做。我不想全额贷款。即使在我神志不清时，我也知道22%的利息太多了。我只想当场支付尽可能多的钱。
I tell them all that I know it's against their policy to take a personal check. But I need to get to the hospital. And if the check bounces, which it won't, they know where to find me. If they can't agree to this, then I'm just going to call a cab and come back another time.
我告诉他们所有人，我知道收个人支票违反他们的政策。但我需要去医院。如果支票跳票了——那是不可能的——他们知道去哪儿找我。如果他们不同意，那我就叫出租车下次再来。
I tell the floor mat guy that I don't give a rip about my options. I'll just take whichever mats come stock with the car. And if I change my mind, I'll come back and upgrade later.
我告诉那个脚垫男，我不关心什么选择。我就要那款随车配的垫子。如果我改变主意，我会再回来升级。
Within 20 minutes, Carolyn has her manager's approval to take my check. And my car is waiting in the front lot.
20分钟内，卡罗琳得到了经理批准，收下了我的支票。我的车就在前院等着。
Carolyn hands me my keys and tells me this is the quickest she's ever seen the car buying process happen in all her time in sales. One last thing, she says. You have to go get insurance. I've already called a local agent, whose office is located two blocks away. She's waiting for you and has your paperwork ready to sign.
卡罗琳把钥匙递给我，说这是她销售生涯中见过最快的购车过程。还有最后一件事，她说。你必须去买保险。我已经给附近两个街区的一家代理商打过电话了。她正在等你，准备好了文件让你签字。
I thank Carolyn. And she wishes me good luck. And I'm off.
我感谢卡罗琳。她祝我好运。我出发了。
I drive to the insurance agents office, only vaguely aware that I am driving my first new car ever. My manic obsession to buy a car, to buy this car, is now overtaken by my manic obsession to get to the hospital.
我开车去保险代理人办公室，只是模糊地意识到我正在开我人生中第一辆新车。我疯狂购买这辆车的执念，现在被我要去医院的疯狂执念所取代。
I'm not aware of it, but I need something tangible in place after I've had this baby that is fighting his way out of my body. I'm not yet aware that after he leaves, I'll transfer all of my maternal love onto this car, that this car will literally help me run away from all the [BLEEP] I've been through and am going through.
我还没意识到，但在我生下这个正在拼命从我体内挣脱出来的婴儿之后，我需要一些有形的东西作为寄托。我还不知道在他离开后，我会把我所有的母爱转移到这辆车上，这辆车将从字面上帮助我逃离我所经历和正在经历的一切[脏话]。
I don't know it yet, but the freedom this car will bring me will help put 130,000 miles of distance between the me that I've been and the me that I will become. I don't know it yet, but tomorrow the nurse will bring newborn Dylan into my hospital room right after Kim calls to announce that her flight has landed and she's on her way.
我还不明白，但车带给我的自由将帮助我在那个“过去的我”和“未来的我”之间拉开13万英里的距离。我还不明白，但明天护士会把刚出生的迪伦带进我的病房，就在金打电话宣布她的航班着陆并正在赶来的路上之后。
Dylan will come in. And I will look down at him. And I will cry. I will tell him, I'm so very sorry that I couldn't keep him, but that I'm positive that I've found a surrogate who's just right, and that I know he'll be loved.
迪伦会进来。我会低头看着他。我会哭。我会告诉他，我很抱歉没能留下他，但我确信我已经找到了一个很棒的代理母亲，我知道他会得到爱的。
I will tell him that I love him, that I will always love him. I also don't know yet that I will stare at him so long that my nipples will start tingling. I will have an almost crippling need to pick him up and place him to my breast and let him nurse. Just for a second, I'll tell myself.
我会告诉他我爱他，我会永远爱他。我还不知道我会盯着他看太久，久到我的乳头会开始刺痛。我会有种几乎瘫痪的冲动想抱起他，把他放在我的乳房上让他喂奶。我告诉自己，就一会儿。
But the moment I start to reach out, the exact moment, my sister will come walking in. And instead of picking Dylan up to breastfeed him, I will pick him up and hand him to his mom. And then-- then I will begin driving.
但就在我伸手的那一刻，就在那一刻，我妹妹走了进来。于是，我没有抱起迪伦喂奶，而是抱起他递给了他的妈妈。然后——然后我开始开车。
Gloria Harrison from Portland, Oregon. A version of her essay first appeared on the website The Nervous Breakdown. That's thenervousbreakdown.com.
来自俄勒冈州波特兰的格洛丽亚·哈里森。她的文章的一个版本首次出现在网站《The Nervous Breakdown》上。网址是thenervousbreakdown.com。
[MUSIC -- "I FOUND MY WAY" BY DUSTY SPRINGFIELD]
[音乐 -- 达斯蒂·斯普林菲尔德的《I FOUND MY WAY》]
Gloria Harrison in Portland, Oregon. A first of her essay first appeared on the website The Nervous Breakdown. That's thenervousbreakdown.com.
俄勒冈州波特兰的格洛丽亚·哈里森。她的文章的一个版本首次出现在网站《The Nervous Breakdown》上。网址是thenervousbreakdown.com。
[MUSIC -- "I FOUND MY WAY" BY DUSTY SPRINGFIELD]
[音乐 -- 达斯蒂·斯普林菲尔德的《I FOUND MY WAY》]
I eat lentils. I don't know where I'm going. I eat lentils. I don't know where I'm going.
我吃扁豆。我不知道要去哪儿。我吃扁豆。我不知道要去哪儿。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多关于《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC -- "THUNDER ROAD" BY BONNIE "PRINCE" BILLY AND TORTOISE]
[音乐 -- 邦妮·“王子”·比利和Tortoise的《THUNDER ROAD》]
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。